hello everyone
and welcome to ipg online meetup
my name is kiki and i'll be your host
today
we are broadcasting live from google
london headquarters
and we are all very excited to have you
joining us today
back by popular demand today marks the
8th rpg online meet up edition
and our goal is to be as interactive and
educational as possible
so in today's session we are joined by
oliver ogg
and paul rohan and we will talk about
driving banking innovation in the age of
assistance
so first ali talking about fa
fis disruption we're gonna have paul
rohan talking about the role of apis
in banking and then we're gonna go to a
fireside
chat as always we will provide you with
plenty of opportunities for participate
participating and asking questions
so before we start few reminders
please ask questions throughout the
session we will have a dedicated time
to answer to all the questions so feel
free to submit them
at any time and also
to ask questions use the link here
or click on the ask question button
on your watch page now i would like to
welcome to the stage
our special guest paul rohan paul
is an author of two books on open
banking
and has a vast experience working with
c-suite
on the area around the world and also
oliver og so without further ado
grab a drink make yourself comfortable
and let's get started
over to ali thanks kiki
so over the last couple of weeks i've
just been keeping an eye on those that
have registered
for this online meetup so welcome but i
see
we've got a lot from the world of
financial services but we do also have
quite a few
who don't directly at least today work
in the world of
financial services so i thought it'd be
a good opportunity
just to take a a holistic view across
what we see
in the world of fis disruption and and
see some key themes that i think are
relevant
to all so first of all uh
the concept of being open so the
fintechs the digital natives are
by default you know as part of their dna
open
they expose their core data their core
services
via apis so that it is extremely
easy for others to work with them
that's quite different from the
incumbents
so ask today in during this meet up you
know what
is right for the business that you work
in and what's the
appetite today it could be a significant
shift
second leveraging data if you work for
an incumbent
you are no doubt sitting on an
extraordinary wealth
of data that i'm sure is not being fully
leveraged
often there are significant challenge
challenges around data
being in silos so at least internally
you know expose
this valuable data set within the
business so that other parts of the
business
can consume it easily but also think
about
these new data products that you could
surface up as apis
to external participants these can be
incredibly valuable
think about the insights that you can
drive
from your scale and the data on which
you
sit on third gravitational pull
so why would others want to work with
you
now it could be that it's incredibly
easy to work with you
it could be your scale perhaps the
number of customers
or the number of products and services
that you offer today
perhaps it's the unique insight that
you've managed to drive out of your
out of your data i it could well be a
combination of
of a number of these so think about what
is the unique value that you can
offer to attract others
your traditional ego uh is
certainly not going to be enough going
forwards
fourth cross-industry ecosystem so we
see this for
two main reasons the first being about
maintaining
relevance so for many businesses today
in order to maintain a continual
relevance to their customers
they are looking to bring additional
products and services
from other industries to the channels
that they own that they can drive
down to their existing customer base so
that as a customer
i'm more continually engaging with that
particular brand
secondly we see it when an industry is
seeing
some level of disruption and the more
severe the disruption the more
cross-industry collaboration we we
observe
and this is a defensive and offensive
play
in in a competitive landscape so
take a take a step back and consider
your organization's own
competitive landscape and again the
appetite
of this cross-industry ecosystem play
and last but not least least the ability
to execute
so there are lots of challenges in doing
this
well there will be organizational
mindset issues there will be
leadership issues there will be
organizational structures
personal egos in the way so this is
uh not a hard there's a way this is not
an easy thing to immediately solve
and of course talent is hard to attract
and maintain so these are five very
common themes that we see
in the world of financial services but
certainly in other industries and
hopefully
will be useful to have in the back of
your mind as we explore this topic
in more depth thanks very much over to
you paul
thank you thank you ali and good morning
everyone
and i'm going to talk about the role of
apis in banking
and while some of my comments a lot of
my comments will be specific to banking
they can probably apply to any really
traditional mature business
that's been around a long time that
wasn't born on the internet
and is now seeing both the threats and
opportunities from digital ecosystems
so i hope to cover four teams today four
topics
and i'm gonna just call them out now to
give you a chance to consider them at a
very high level
and maybe perhaps contribute any
questions that you have to our
discussion
and we have a fantastic vantage point at
google apogee
in that not only do we serve a lot of
banks
and financial services companies
globally but we work across
every vertical and we think there's
something much bigger happening than
just
banking or open banking which we would
call the age of assistance
which i'll come on and describe in a bit
more detail but we think to be relevant
and responsive and fast in the age of
systems
you know api products aren't just an
optional extra
excuse me we think they're absolutely
essential
secondly the world of digital ecosystems
are radically different in terms of
how people think and behave in terms of
growing their business and managing
their business strategy and technology
and managing their brands
and there's lots of discussion around
mindset and corporate culture
but to be really explicit here we're
saying we think
work is required on both computer
systems and belief systems
sounds a bit odd but come on to discuss
that in a bit more detail
and we think it's insufficient just to
do work on your computer systems
and not work on your belief systems we
think this will prevent you scaling
or certainly getting the full benefits
of digital ecosystems
then i think brand is very important
brand strategy okay for a couple of
reasons for several reasons in fact
firstly brand strategy has a much longer
duration than
business strategy or technology strategy
so
your technology strategy or your
business strategy might have one or two
years to run
whereas brand strategies very long term
five to ten year thinking
what type of emotional reaction and
response do we want to get from the
marketplace
far broader than just our specific
products and services
and often people who are from a pure
technology background
say to me you know banks are in terrible
trouble are the banking industries in
terrible trouble
their user interfaces their user
experiences aren't good
you know they must be out of business in
a few years and my response is well
you know we need to reflect on that
because the banking industry
based on which historian you believe
could be up to 4 000 years old
so it has thrived and survived many
evolutions and technology
so we have a view from much observation
that
maybe the the brand purpose of financial
brands won't be changed hugely
by digital ecosystems and however brand
audiences
will be changed in a very radical way
and then lastly
what will be a great financial brand
experience in the era
of digital ecosystems and in the age of
assistance
and we think that the the financial
brands that treat
uh developers as customers and approach
them entirely as they would approach
customers
are the most likely to scale and succeed
in this world
so firstly what do we mean by the age of
assistance
and in the context of that we think it's
very much a hyper-connected world
and we would define this as that it's
impacting all services not just
financial services
and that customers are now expecting
their favorite brands to work together
to provide connected experiences in
digital ecosystems
and if that sounds a bit far away or
theoretical for a traditional financial
services company
you need to consider many aspects of
this
but focus in on customer journeys
so how does your company define customer
journeys
is it a long time since you've reflected
on what they mean do you mean customer
journeys by
they knock on the door of your store or
your branch or they knock on the door
of your proprietary digital app and then
customer journey management
is ushering them to the right solution
the right
product to consider the suitable service
that you have for that stage of their
life cycle
the big concern for companies that are
adopting that mindset
is that there's a new generation of
buyers whether they are
young consumers or young businesses who
expect who are on a journey through a
digital ecosystem
and they expect their favorite brands
and favorite providers
to collaborate and provide a connected
end-to-end experience
so in reality they're on a journey to
the ecosystem and if you wish to serve
them and remain relevant and one of
their favorite brands
you need to push your services out there
into that environment
and let them use those services through
whichever interface
is suitable and appropriate and
contextual
so in that context rethinking what you
mean by a customer journey
and focusing in on the young generation
and how they see customer journeys
causes a major rethink of not just your
brand strategy
but also your business strategy your
business architecture
your technical strategy and if all of
these things are going to work
your mindset and this mindset needs to
be shared
right across the organization across all
key roles from the top to the bottom
we talk to many banks about digital
transformation
and often their focus can be quite
narrow
and they believe that transformation
involves using new technologies and
doing new things
and doing things in new ways and often
we have to remind them the
transformation is a combination of two
things
it's both starting the new ways doing
new things doing it
with new technologies but also
effectively stopping the old ways
stopping using the old technologies stop
using the old methods
and it's useful to consider the age of
assistance from from this perspective
so we would argue very strongly that in
the age of assistance
only api enabled collaboration is going
to help you keep up
and it's going to be relevant so look at
some of the ways in which a traditional
financial services company
or indeed any traditional organization
might partner
and they would have historically focused
on things like joint ventures or
strategic alliances
and a joint venture is incredibly
precise and that a separate organization
is set up to do it
but it's plagued with problems it's very
slow to get together
you can have a clash of cultures inside
the new organization from people from
two different organizations
it takes incredible amount of
pre-planning and if it doesn't work out
it's very hard to exit strategic
alliances aren't quite as rigid
but they're very very loose and they're
slow to get to market
you're assembling projects and by side
both organizations and it's tough enough
to assemble a project inside one
organization
but to collaborate across two
organizations using projects is
incredibly difficult
so very hard to coordinate and ambiguous
about who's doing what
and the crucial flaw that both of them
share apart from being slow or rigid or
loose
is that it's not reusable it's specific
to that collaboration
whereas api enabled partnering the
investment is reusable
so you try out an api but one partner
turns out to be a good api but the wrong
partner
moves swiftly on to the next one it's
faster market
there's automated processes behind the
apis which everyone can trust
there's automated fast onboarding
companies that go partnering use the
apis
move from onboarding of partners that
last months
into onboarding your partners that last
hours
and there's low barriers to exit the
investment is reusable
you can move on to other partnerships
and other ideas and other collaborations
incredibly quickly
and within this world you can come
across unanticipated opportunities with
your apis
that no one in your organization could
have imagined before you publish those
apis
so we have a strong view about the age
of assistance we think it straddles all
verticals not just banking
so we sell api management software
you buy our software the problem is
sorted that's not the case we think
there's a lot more to be done than
changing computer systems to handle apis
if you wish to be successful in this
world as a financial brand
so onto belief systems and we like to
think that we are
incredibly clinical in our business
environment that we make every
cold-blooded analytical economic
decisions
and that is the case but those decisions
are built upon a base
of assumptions and beliefs about how the
marketplace works
how to grow in the marketplace how to
present services to the marketplace
how to segment the marketplace the
crucial thing about belief systems is
that they are systems
that people believe all elements of the
system
not just one it's not a pick and mix or
they can where they can select
so in that context we think the world
the age of assistance
and the digital ecosystems that are
serving in the age of assistance
does require quite a radically different
belief system a set of beliefs
that are not only relevant and effective
in isolation
but all connect to each other and that
these
beliefs drive a common set of behaviors
and assumptions right across the
organization
which means you can scale cohesively
whatever technology strategy pursuing
or whatever business strategy you're
pursuing
so for fun it's this harkens back to
those old
tv ads for uh soap powder do you prefer
brand a or or brand b
but let's consider financial brand and
financial brand b that are looking to
world of ecosystems
and let's hypothesize that brand a has
bought themselves a brand spanking new
computer system an api management
platform for ecosystems
but there hasn't been a general
discussion and revision of
the belief system why are we doing this
how's the market going to operate how
should we present ourselves
and then brand b which is not only
working on computer systems but is
having a long and deep and broad
discussion from the top to the bottom of
the organization
about what they should believe about
ecosystems and how this is going to
guide their decision making
so a simplified but we think effective
summary of two belief systems
you can tell we have the one we like in
green and the one we're not so sure
about in red
but the way to read this slide is is
down in sequence
so belief systems are our systems and
all of the individual beliefs connect to
each other so there's many traditional
services organizations
which for the last 20 or 30 years if
they were asked
what did they believe about innovation
and business development
they would say well it's the job of our
staff and because it's difficult and
slow we're doing everything ourselves
we tend to focus on large market
segments to make it economic
and you know if we're a bank we try to
have banking products that are better
than our peers
and we have to control the distribution
pretty much
up to the line the point of sale and
because
we're doing everything ourselves and
we're using projects to collaborate with
partners
we can handle a small number of partners
and
to because we believe our logo is our
brand and drives recognition of our
brand
we want our customers to always use our
digital interface
and we broadcast loads of marketing
messages to try and get them to come to
that interface
and this is not a common belief system
amongst
many of the more modern services
companies that have grown up
whether they're fintechs or other types
of new services companies
they have an entirely different set of
beliefs that all hang together that they
want their ecosystem
partners to drive the innovation and
that they want to be in
the a in ecosystems of collaborating
enterprises that can reach very small
market segments
that they couldn't reach on their own
and that their brand experience is
driven by
how the brand behaves inside an
ecosystem and the crucial skill for
distribution is orchestrating the
behavior of partners
and that apis are fantastic because they
allow you when you use them as products
to manage very large partner population
to drive your growth
and if we think back to the 1960s and
the use of the
the development of the marketing mix
which had four ps initially
product place price and promotion these
companies believe that the p for place
is the digital interface that happens to
be convenient for the customer at that
point in time
doing what they're doing in their daily
lives so in a banking context
the p for place has changed from the
digital interface that the bank prefers
to the digit interface that the com the
customer happens to prefer
this is a profound change which gives
rise to significant changes
in computer systems and overall belief
systems
and these organizations that operate in
with the belief systems that's
orientated towards ecosystems
they're not obsessed with their brand as
a logo they're obsessed with getting the
meaning
of what they do and crucially why they
do it
to communicate it to their end users so
that they can form an emotional bond
with those clients so that those clients
will go looking for those services
as they go about their daily lives so
radically different belief systems
and we believe that the banks that work
on just their computer systems and don't
consider
their belief systems for ecosystems will
struggle to scale
because they'll have a highly incoherent
internal environment about how exactly
they're trying to grow
and innovate and partner
so this is a simple graphic we use in
apogee around the digital value chain
and this is the the old digital value
chain and brand audience as we see it
which is financial brands pushing out
their services exclusively by and large
through their own brand app and trying
to both provide services
and form an emotional brand with a brand
audience made up of customers
we think this is the expanded digital
value chain for ecosystems
and it expands the brand audience
where you're trying to get the same
message about what you have but also
why you do it that message out to both
developers and customers
in this environment and that's a crucial
thing because the brand specialist will
tell you that
what you do is is important for your
services
but what creates long-term emotional
connections to your clients is that they
understand
why you do it so you need to get that
message of why you do it
and why it's valuable for society and
the economy and for the customer
out there and have developers buy into
that too
so if you're a financial brand these are
the type of
brand messages that are broadcast and
that
company tries to live up to every day
which is they're on a long term journey
with their clients they want their
clients to prosper
and sleep easily at night they want to
protect them from harm they want to be
the financial experts
they want to be available where their
clients need them they want to introduce
relevant other services
these are these are parts of
of the brand purpose of a bank that can
go back hundreds of years
and they will go forward hundreds of
years into the future no matter what
technologies evolve
but in digital ecosystems the same
experience
of the brand needs to be experienced by
third-party developers
who should by using the developer
program at the financial brand
feel that the financial brand is on a
long term journey with them helping them
prosper
helping them sleep at night you know
being the financial experts being
analytical about the use of apis being
structured
protecting them from harm in terms of
how the apis are managed
being available when they're needed and
connected to other wider services
so same financial purpose in broad terms
for financial brand
their job is to look after financial
concerns of people in the economy and in
society
but digital ecosystems radically expands
the brand audience
so financial brands compete with each
other and they need to compete to become
the favorite brands
within the ecosystems both for their
customers and for third parties
and we would argue that the best
approach inside your traditional
financial brand
is to have the same belief system for
customers and developers
developers are customers so
it's useful to explore that topic in a
bit more detail
so in that context it's absolutely
natural for bankers today
to go to work in the morning and without
setting out their assumptions or their
belief systems
every task they do that day is based on
this belief
that they want as many customers at the
entry level of their service offering as
possible
as many as possible at entry level and
they want feedback from the customers
good bad and ugly feedback they want it
so they can improve
they want to pay attention particular
attention to the most valuable
or strategic customers the most active
ones the most profitable ones the most
promising ones
this is a natural assumption that
underpins decision making every day
they want to assign suitable staff to
deal with particular types of customers
with the right qualifications and skills
and attitudes and temperaments and you
want your customers to be prosperous
a financial brands want prosperous
customers
because that's the key to prosperity and
profit for the financial brand
you want to onboard customers quickly
and easily and you differentiate
the services that you offer customers
and every day
without specifying that this is the
underpinning belief
banker set about solving problems for
their customers
we would argue very strongly in the
world of digital ecosystems that the
exact same philosophy
around your brand experience should be
applied to third-party developers
you want as many as possible at the
entry level and we find
many bankers and traditional companies
getting hung up on this um
and we tried to say listen you want to
start with it's just like funneling
customers you want as many possible
customers at the top of the funnel and
then you filter them
you want as many possible developers at
the top of the funnel and then you
filter them
and that should be should be the goal of
your developer marketing program
you want their input it's going to be
tough for some traditional companies
when they first
begin their developer program and even
if they manage the apis very well
they are providing a gateway into into
potentially old systems or new
abstractions of data from old systems
you will get some very very tough
feedback but that feedback loop is going
to be absolutely essential
so we see many banks that are incredibly
slow getting mobilized
and they're very anxious about the end
state of where is this all going to end
up in terms of new market structures
and our encouragement is listen you have
to get started you have to create that
feedback loop
you can't stay here theorizing about how
this is going to work
for another three years you need to get
started you'll get feedback
good bad and ugly the bank that gets
started and starts to mobilize and gets
the most feedback
will refine their offering will get
stronger and will form
a queue of developers and will start to
generate network effects
you want to filter your developers get
the most informational and profitable
ones
and in terms of that filtration
monetization is a tactic
we see many banks getting hung up on the
idea of api monetization
i want to be paid for all my apis i want
to know who's going to use them
how much they're going to use them with
what volume this is not effective
consider how banks consider bank fees
for certain segments of the market like
startups businesses
or student university students
they they don't charge fees because or
they charge lower fees because
these are strategically valuable market
segments in the long term
other banking customers get discounts
for
using a lot of banking services because
they're using them at volume so they get
a volume discounts
other fees are decided and charged based
on the nature of usage the volume of
usage
the future potential of usage and in
many cases
highly valuable banking clients that do
a lot of borrowing or do a lot of
depositing
don't pay any fees the exact same
principles apply to api monetization
it's a tactic
if there is a developer that's driving a
huge amount of business traffic
that allows lots of uh deposits to be
taken in
or lots of new lending to be done then
you can be quite relaxed about
how much you charge for the use of the
apis you're getting lots of valuable
referrals
you don't need to charge that developer
for api usage
so it's just a tactic um and you learn
as you go and you'll refine your pricing
tactics around apis
crucially you want developers to be
prosperous just like you want your
customers to be prosperous
and this is something to focus in on
because we see some banks getting very
hesitant
in case third-party developers combine
their banking apis into third-party
services
and have a big success and bankers feel
that in some way
we've lost out on a big opportunity even
though we would never have had that idea
ourselves
or we would never have collaborated with
that partner ourselves
and they need to get over this because
there's no better developer marketing
than having one of your developers have
a big success with your apis
you want a big queue of developers to
follow you want as many developers as
possible at the entry level
you need to onboard them quickly and
easily just like customers and just like
banks try to differentiate their banking
services
you need to differentiate uh your apis
make them faster make them more data
rich make the documentation better
make the people who manage your api
program more progressive
more knowledgeable make them more better
relationship managers
and in this evolution because banking is
thousands of years old
bankers will come to the office and the
only difference will be
is that they want to solve problems of
both their customers and third party
developers with the same energy
and the same purpose um because they'll
be part of their brand audience
and they will serve their brand purpose
and will drive new growth and new
innovation and partnering for banks and
financial services companies
in digital ecosystems
so there there are strong conclusions
that apogee has derived from
its its um
fantastic vantage point in the
marketplace across all verticals
and there they are again delighted to
deal in our fireside chat
if people have questions or ideas uh
related to these
okay
all right uh so now let's pause and get
some questions from the audience
and once more to ask questions please
use the link here or click on the ask
question button
on your watch page
so the first question here
some people say ecosystems will turn
banks into dump pipes what do you think
about that paul
akiki we we get this question a lot okay
and sometimes we have to try and unpick
it of what you mean by dump pipes
but in many ways we see it as a cultural
reaction
to new customer journeys which other
companies are generating and a feeling
that
if you're not in full control of the
entire journey yourself with your logo
on the front
that something major has been lost and
all we can do is step back from that and
ask well forget about pipes
what might be dumb going forward okay
and coming back to the age of assistance
where
young people are increasingly used to
these connected journeys with their
favorite brands collaborating and
providing
a seamless experience where they might
end up buying several things
from several companies but it's been one
connected experience
you have to ask yourself is it dumb to
broadcast messages to those
young people those young businesses that
are becoming increasingly enmeshed in
this world
saying come and look at our proprietary
app come and look break the chain
break your concentration break the
convenience and come and read up on what
we have
and you'll probably find it marginally
better as a core product
than something you've just bought too
late
okay so in the context of that we would
say step back
because it's a very emotional statement
and ask
what in this there's an environmental
change coming but financial services
are still very valuable and rare it's
very hard to get a license particularly
to take deposits
highly regulated you need a lot of
capital this is not a business that many
organizations will get into easily so in
that context
we ask banks to separate the core
purpose of what they do as bankers and
how
all services are changing and once they
step back from that
we find the question of dom pipe dom
pipe will be a dump pipe
is far less sinister and then they start
to see the upside
which is if i'm not fully in control of
the customer journey yes perhaps my logo
is not on every screen
but if i use api products i can be in 10
times as many customer journeys
and i can have a realistic aspiration to
double my sales okay
um when i'm in 10 times as many customer
journeys
and if you've doubled your sales that's
going to pay for a lot of marketing
budget to help get across your brand
message
okay so we ask people to step through it
but it is a question and it does
reflect this belief system that we think
is very established but increasingly
might be the wrong belief system
to have about how bankers should
distribute their services
that's great thank you so much thanks so
much from that
uh thanks for the questions uh
we're gonna start the fireside chat now
uh and i just would like to remind you
that we will
keep asking uh answering questions
during the fireside chat so
please keep them going coming over to
you ali
great thanks kiki uh paul a
fantastic session um you've got this
unique global perspective
often traveling around the world um when
you look across
the entire landscape i mean who's kind
of leading the way yeah
we see a lot of leaders and laggards and
but
it's it's difficult to define an
absolute
leader based on geography okay
um because there's different
environmental factors
so there's developing economies for
example where
there's never been home broadband
there's never been a home laptops
uh there's a whole new generation of
people getting connected to the internet
for the first time
uh that they're it's all mobile it's all
cellular
and to give context 10 years ago
one third of the world's global middle
classes who are heavy users of banking
services
from financial brands was in asia in 10
more years
so in a 20-year shift two-thirds of the
global middle classes would be in asia
and those new consumers of banking
services will never have had home
broadband will never at home laptop it
will all be
mobile it'll all be cellular and in that
context
uh there's banks in asia who are only
building apis
and not building apps because they don't
think apps are going to scale it's going
to be hundreds of millions of people who
are new customers with different
languages
they'll be part of the platform economy
they might be managing their daily lives
through a chinese platform or through an
american platform
or another in indian platform they need
to expose banking
apis so they're very advanced with apis
but they're driven by their environment
where we see
in regions where we see leaders that are
more progressive
as institutions we think it comes down
to executive leadership
okay because things like talking about a
new belief system and a new brand
strategy for ecosystem
that's a c-suite job okay and when
you're trying to do
new use new techniques like apis in new
market segments with new partners
you know people get a lot more nervous
about things going wrong then
there are tried and tested methods that
they've used every day
for for years and everyone knows what to
expect
and most risk management techniques have
been worked out
so a lot less nervous so
and you know when there's a setback in a
very mature environment
people get over it faster and move on
whereas a setback in this brand new
world where people are uncertain feel
like the sky is falling in
okay so as people are making the
transition
we think into this new mindset and a new
belief system
not only do the c-suite need to fire
their starting gun
but they need to stay engaged okay
because they're learning
people are learning and you need to
c-suite to constantly keep that
strategic goal in mind
it's a setback it's a mistake let's fix
it move on move on move on
we're entering into a new unfamiliar
strange market
it's like landing in a foreign country
we don't know the people we don't know
the best segments we don't know the best
products to sell
we've got to get around the place and
figure out how it works and then we'll
set very tough targets for ourselves and
then we'll scale
so we deal with a lot of organizations
and the ones that are least tentative
and most progressive
and get over the learning experiences
faster are the ones where the c-suite
call out the call out the culture
changes as well as the technology
changes
and then don't just treat it as another
project come back to us in six months
when you're finished
because the odds of being a success in a
very
established environment is radically
reduced if they don't stay engaged
so leadership comes from
leadership right and how much
permission does a bank have to get from
let's say the regulator
you know is that almost an excuse to to
execute
uh because there must be some reasons
where i guess the regulate the local
regulator has yet to say
you you must do this yeah the the
regulation environments
do differ but
bankers can get frustrated very
frustrated sometimes with what the
regulators specify
and some of that's justified and some of
it's not but you have to ask yourselves
why are regulators doing this or even
considering this
okay because they issue licenses
to people to run banks that will finance
the growth of the economy
okay so regulators are looking at how
the economy is evolving
and it's the age of assistance companies
are connecting to each other
consumer experiences are are are highly
digital and highly connected
and regulars are setting a policy
framework
around consent and privacy
and all of those conduct rules but
they're there to underpin
good practice in a world that's getting
connected okay
so we encourage our clients to step okay
yes article 58 might be ambiguous and
frustrating and
if only the regulators around the world
would get together and synchronize
everything
put that aside and ask yourselves what
why are they doing this
why are they doing this and not only is
it the age of assistance and banks if
they want to stay connected to their
customers need to
connect but regulators with whatever
degree of effectiveness
are setting up setting themselves up to
regulate conduct
in the age of assistance so step up to
the why
and we think that some banks that get
obsessed about
regulatory micro decisions are at risk
of missing the big picture
because then they send a team over in
the corner to deal with the regulations
and what they should be doing is getting
the whole organization to consider
how do we develop and persist with our
brand in this
new way of services being designed and
delivered and consumed
great great um so i i guess i i see a
common kind of dichotomy of execution
between um
those that just see it uh open banking
as a regulatory tax
to those that are desperately trying to
engage with fintechs perhaps definitely
trying to spin up you know viable
ventures within you know large
larger groups and there's a lot of so if
we shift the
perhaps conversation from regulatory to
the innovation spectrum
there's a lot of innovation theater
going on in the industry i mean
what are some of some of the kind of
common pitfalls that you see um
[Music]
i think most of our cultural in that we
even
i think it's it's a step forward and a
step back
to create an innovation department in
the corner where everyone takes their
ties off and you have bean bags instead
of desks
okay it's a step forward and that we
need to loosen up
and think about doing things in new ways
and with new partners and in new
segments
but at the same time to with the wrong
leadership our insufficient leadership
it becomes well that's their that's
their job
and incremental minor changes is
business as usual
so in the context of that um
there's a socialization challenge right
across the organization and i feel for
some traditional banks
i i i sometimes for fun we say we think
they're making progress because we see
the suits
okay with the ties on but actually
talking in detail about
the culture of the ecosystem and how do
i grow and yes i need to do the
governance yes into the risk management
but how much is enough how much is too
much
and so therefore you have to ask
yourself what does the ecosystem
want from banks they want stuff that
non-banks can't do
this stuff they want stuff that you
can't do without a license
all of that stuff that is regulated
because badly managed banks blow up
economies so therefore they get
regulated so once you start to say well
what what do we have that's valuable and
rare
as a bank that's hard for non-banks to
imitate or substitute
that's the core it's payments at high
scale it's loans at high scale it's
deposits at high scale it's investments
that i scale
and that's the old systems you need to
get the data abstract out of those
systems
turn into apis start to learn the
feedback from the developers
so there is no shortcut and the risk is
that innovation theater which can be
superficial
delays the real innovation which is
what do we do that no one else can do
because the ecosystem wants it
and this kind of ties into my next
question and and
something you just referred to earlier
around failure and learning
yeah when you're working with c-suite do
you
do you talk about that and then perhaps
a bit more detail to because i think
that i see others sort of pronounce it
as if you know this is a
this is okay to do but actually i think
when when it
came to it uh failure would not be
accepted
and heads would be removed i think you
have to
i think you have to connect failure to
projects culture okay
so why does the traditional organization
fear failure so much
because projects are terrible okay they
are
really compared to business as usual
they're incredibly difficult to execute
they're temporary and unique management
structures full of people who are
reporting to different people
on temporary assignment most of them
don't reach their goals
and inevitably the vast amount of work
they do is not reusable
so when you're trying to innovate and
partner particularly through
projects failure is a horrible prospect
a
it's likely and b it's really expensive
okay
so i don't you can just say failure in
isolation i think fear of failure comes
from
feeling that there's no alternative to
projects okay and they're an expensive
way to fail because
for all of those reasons we just said so
in that context when you're trying to
say listen api products
if you systematically start to build
them and use them and market them
and get feedback on them your failures
are
far more economic so far faster okay
the stuff you did to reach the fader far
faster is reusable a lot of it's
reusable
and you're actively marketing the
outcome from your init
your innovation to not just the first
person to use it
but to the next hundred who could use it
so i think if you
if you when people say listen where
everyone's afraid of failure here is no
it's
people are afraid of failure because
they think there's no scalable
valuable alternatives to projects
culture
there is api products culture okay and i
think once that
feeling starts to once that
understanding starts to come
and then crucially supported from the
top then the idea of
partnering is api enabled it's reusable
investment
i can exit quickly if the partner turns
out to disappoint they don't produce the
volume
it's reusable there's automation behind
it i have a marketing program
it's as much it's an entire new belief
system around how you're going to
collaborate
then projects and it's awful i hate it
how do i get off this thing yeah
great um i had a moment of realization
actually this year when i was uh
in a forum of maybe 18 c-suite of
mia insurers mainly cios
um and we were the topic was ecosystems
uh but i very rapidly realized actually
that um quite a few
had come to that session with uh a
mindset that an ecosystem included kind
of strategic alliances
so i had to really kind of bring that
room along into
saying well actually you know this this
is our perspective is that
something that you see in the world of
banking as well because you know i guess
banks have been at the core of
an ecosystem yeah yeah i think the
medicis here you know very vibrant
ecosystems for
for hundreds of years yeah sorry i'm not
saying that that
strategic alliances will never be used
but if you want to have
a thousand partners in an ecosystem
driving your growth you won't do it
through strategic alliances it has to be
api
enabled partnering um i do think there's
a key part of the cultural shift
so you have to say to people sometimes
listen
you're talking to fintechs at the moment
or you're looking at potential partners
and
you you imagine who it might be and you
organize a lunch you talk about how you
might
collaborate um and then you assemble
projects in your respective organization
you know even this description of it is
slow okay
um but consider what you define by a
partnering opportunity
should it be when somebody who you've
never met has started consuming your
apis and not just consuming it
doing it in ways that you would never
have thought about is bringing your
services into new segments that you
never reached on your own
they're paying for the privilege now is
the time to have a lunch
and say should this be a strategic
alliance so
coming back to the idea of treating
developers as customers
you want as many possible partners at
the entry level
and then begin the filtration process
through api monetization
and then so if you think about fintechs
and banks we're talking to a lot of
fintechs
and there's been a lot of lunches and
lots of beers and lots of coffees
the question should be now can you use
apis to filter those
fintechs that want to talk to your bank
into those that
can just talk and those who can talk and
actually simultaneously drive traffic
into your organization through your apis
and pay for it right great and i see
there's a question that's come
through that's somewhat related to the
theme of ecosystems so let's ask this
one
uh does google or just rephrase it
slightly does has google created a
marketplace for financial services
or will you do
it's a very big oiling title uh
marketplace for financial services
um financial services is an incredibly
broad church
in terms of what it offers from the most
sophisticated
investment clients down to the simplest
startup or
junior savings account and google is a
global organization
so in the context of has google created
a marketplace for financial services
it's hard to describe what that might be
okay there's no doubt that
if you step back and consider ecosystems
as
as a place where there are connected
experiences across their favorite brands
google is a very popular brand people
connect through google pay
through banks connect to google maps
they connect to all sorts of google
digital assets
that type of you know are you going to
create something monolithic
where you can see it's a connected
economy in the age of assistance
google has vast numbers of apis vast
numbers of collaborating partners
step back from thinking that there's
going to be huge moves by
horizontal organizations or vertical
organizations
people should consider what will be the
design of the overall marketplace for
all systems
and for all services so you're going to
find insurance companies
are going to be dabbling in segments
that they would never have touched when
they had their old business model
but now we'll make some money out of
stuff that's
very partially related to insurance
banks will start to make money out of
non-banking activities and ecosystems
so we we often we think that developing
strategy
based on the positioning of other
companies
is increasingly impossible so
10 years ago you could do a strategy
session and everyone does the swot
analysis on the wall strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats
and when fintechs came along bankers
would write
collaboration with 100 fintech names
down as an opportunity
and then they'd put the same hundred
fintech names down as a threat
okay and all that said was you can't
devise a strategy that everyone in the
company
understands and is pursuing based on
what are those 47 rivals and potential
rivals doing now
okay if there's a big shift to the
design of the market and how it operates
you have to shift your positioning
towards that design
so analysts have described strategy of
it's a plan
and it's a position and it's a pattern
of activity
and all different ways to look at it and
we think the pattern of activity is
changing radically
follow the pattern of activity in terms
of how you behave
trying to figure out what 100 other
companies are going to do
might be an interesting discussion to
have over coffee
however it doesn't produce anything
sensible for your organization
to figure out in terms of its priorities
for the age of assistance
great so let's say tomorrow you go go
home and on the on the on your on your
doorstep is a letter from a bank with a
you know a very attractive offer and you
become you want to become the cio
okay you've had enough of the the google
kale a random inflatable dinosaurs yeah
for whatever um no more green trails no
more green
chinos um now you're looking at this
future and
technology landscape of aiml
apis blockchain what's the right level
of focus a cio should have
on this future landscape for apis
i i think it was thomas edison said that
you know genius is one percent
inspiration 99 is perspiration
so for a traditional bank and the cio
getting the valuable services out of the
core legacy systems and into and up
into an api layer that's going to be a
lot of perspiration
okay and there's no shortcuts and
but as that's happening the one percent
of the time that's the most valuable
is is evangelizing for the change in
market dynamics
and in some of those topics we've just
discovered looking for
inspiration in what's happening in other
service industries
in terms of how they're using apis in
ecosystems
and focusing on developers as a new
brand audience
to make sure that they come to have the
same respect and affinity to your bank
as
your customers but arguably
say very strongly to banker colleagues
really the purpose of a bank hasn't
changed
how services are designed and developed
and delivered
are changing across all service
industries but financial services
remains
quite a small regulated
highly capitalized tough business it's
not going to not every business is going
to get into it
we just need to rethink the services
part of financial services the financial
bit might not change that much
we have lots of perspiration to get the
financial services out of the old
systems
into apis um but then more broadly
see it as a huge opportunity okay
there's going to be 10 times as many
customer journeys we can be in
if we have api products that can connect
okay
so i don't think being cio of a
traditional bank with all systems is an
easy job
it can be made easier if all of these
belief system issues
are surfaced and discussed at the top of
the organization
and then once any organization once
everyone starts
adopting the same mindset and going in
the same direction
any organization can produce phenomenal
outcomes
great uh we're coming close to the end
of the time for the fireside chat we'll
obviously have
audience questions questions in a moment
um you mentioned
the constrained issuing of licenses but
i guess
that that you know probably banks have
been
maybe complacent to the wrong word but
there's been the safety net of that
um but obviously that that has changed
to a degree right there's been more
that's been issued
um and it kind of ties into a question
really around trust as well so
there's a safety net of this very
valuable concept of trust
yeah how much can banks rely on
the existing license world regulatory
license world and
their their perception of trust in the
marketplace
to protect them from disruption i think
they worry too much because many of the
new licenses that have been issued
are to initiate financial transactions
they're not necessarily to
settle transaction financial
transactions at scale
certainly a license to take deposits
from the public
is still something that regulators don't
you know
hand out too easily because a public
panic and runs on banks
is something that can cause a 10-year
recession in your economy with a loss of
confidence
um so yes there's a lot more
licenses and with psd2 and open banking
initiatives
to allow non-banks or more likely
regulated financial institutions
initiate payments
but much of the profitability of the
industry is driven by
the ability to take large amounts of
deposits from the public
pay two percent on average lend back to
the public possibly to
tend to be to younger businesses and
younger people at
six or seven percent because you need to
cover the small number who don't pay
back their loans and
other risks in relation to that process
so
in the context of that i don't see you
know
licenses to build a balance sheet being
thrown out too easily because these
balance sheets
the health of these balance sheets are
connected to the health of the economy
so i do think that banks need to get
their heads around what's
what is initiation of payments and the
abstraction of account data
and what actually is the providing of
core banking services
and then recognize that in the in this
evolution is opportunities for
partnering
at scale that they never had before but
these part
these opportunities will mean nothing if
they don't have api products
to make those partner partnerships fast
flexible reusable
um and in time the market will get to a
new steady state
with this new dominant design of how
things happen um
and my personal view is that banking
will thrive
and will expand because of the expanded
opportunities in ecosystems
the question is which banks will make
the transition effectively and which
banks won't
fantastic a great summary there as well
um if i just go into uh perhaps some
kind of takeaways that i've really
learned from that fantastic conversation
i think
you know what i found really that the
position how we
position this to be really valuable i i
hope to the audience uh
no matter what industry just kind of
this uh a reset of you know the
opportunity
for the industry and load up for your
your business the positioning around
the criticality of leadership uh
not only just understanding this but
really continually driving it
um and that developers are customers and
should be prosperous i love that idea
um and then i liked your idea that with
digital transformation there's often
this focus of uh new things and new ways
but
you know critically stopping the old
ways don't don't forget that very
important point
thanks very much paul all right thank
you very much that was really
interesting
uh now we're gonna take some more
questions from the audience
and as a reminder uh please use the link
here to ask questions
or click on the ask question button on
your watch page
all right so we have another question
here so
what can other territories who have yet
to do anything about open banking
learn from what the eu and the uk
uh have done
i i think i i think there are there's
actually
quite a distinctive difference between
how the eu has approached us
and how the um uk has approached it
so the uk was had embarked on this
initiative
which was driven to create more in
retail banking before pst 2 came on the
horizon
um and in some ways our have
definitely has an implementation body
and has more precise
guidance on how services should be
designed and for countries that are
thinking about moving into the world of
open banking the uk provides a fantastic
template
that mobilizes your banking community
quite quickly
and where i think the eu is interesting
uh
globally is it has a huge regulatory
machine because
since the 1960s
europe has been creating a single market
okay so there's a perception that
this is all new red tape no it's just
the centralization of red tape
um and their europe hasn't been needed
at digital
and they're working very very hard to
make that happen but i wouldn't look at
psd2 in isolation
so psd2 is looking for api connectivity
between banks and third parties it's
setting out conduct rules
um but there's things like gdpr setting
out
expectations around consent
there's european work going on around
identity
and so i think what the rest of the
world should look to is
whether your regulator is going to be
very precise about rules or whether your
regulator is going to give general
guidance around principles
what this work that's happening in
europe identifies is
the world is going incredibly digital
organizations going to be
um connected to each other and
regulators will have expectations of
good behavior and bad behavior
and it's in the interest of the
leadership and the board of directors of
an organization to go what are these
regulators defining as good behavior and
bad behavior
in terms of conduct by enterprises and
whether we have a regulation or not you
know
we should take that as our cue for to
protect our brand in the long term
when we write policy documents about
being in ecosystems
what is our policy around consent when
we say to our customers we have partners
what do we mean by partners okay when we
say to our customers we're partnering
with somebody
how do we make it absolutely plain and
simple to them that we're doing this bit
the partner's doing that bit we're
taking proper care that we're choosing
good partners
but you just need to read the
instructions so i think
for bank for for organizations that
aren't in the regulatory space
you have the luxury of not having to
obsess over what are they saying in
article 58
but go back to the preamble of the
documentation when they say
why they're doing it these are the type
of outcomes that we want in terms of
consumer trust and consumer protection
okay
and that these powerful organizations
don't abuse their position so
when you read why they're doing it and
the expectations they have generally
about
conduct that's a very useful starting
point
because one of the things that's holding
up organizations getting heavy engaged
in ecosystems
is going we don't have any policy
documents from risk department about how
we should conduct ourselves
well copy and paste the principles that
the regulators are
espousing and maybe be glad you don't
have to follow detailed rules that
regulators have written
great great
um okay so
thanks so much for the questions i hope
we've
you found this useful and interesting we
also would love to hear your feedback
so please send your thoughts via the
feedback form that you can see here
uh the link and also stay tuned
because we have the next online meetup
coming in march 27th
so please send your ideas so we can make
the next edition
even better and with that
we're getting to the end of today's
session thanks so much for joining
have a great christmas and i see you
next time
you